i think people make they create a
dichotomy a false dichotomy
that they have to either choose service
or individual success
right that those two are somehow
mutually exclusive
um and that service means uh living a a
life of suffering right
which is nonsense um and and then you
hear these silly
these silly uh um sort of uh uh
projections like
i'm gonna do well so that i can do good
so i'm gonna put myself
first and then eventually i'll do good
for others
you know a a friend of mine who's a
philanthropist
someone came to him for advice on
philanthropy and this was a former ceo
of a very large company
and um and my friend asked him so what
what are you most proud of in your
philanthropy
and he said well you know we started
this charity in the inner city where we
help
kids uh go on to college and he said
that's amazing
you know how many kids have you helped
he said 15 he says is that the proudest
thing you've done
you know in your life he says yeah i'm
really proud and my friend said so let
me understand this you're proud of 15
kids you helped go to college
meanwhile you destroyed the lives of the
60 000 people who worked for you
you know um uh like
that's that's what happens when you uh
do well so that you can do good you put
yourself at the center of the equation
and then eventually
you'll try and even the the scale so you
can feel good before you die
um um and the uh and and the reality is
the opposite is true
do well uh sorry do good and you can
also do well
right um but doing good should not be
something that we save
for our retirement um doing good is
something that we can do every day and
and and and it's remarkably easy
i mean what your neighbor did for you
just by looking out his window
was good saying hello asking somebody
how are you and actually caring about
the answer saying please and thank you
you know i mean these are very very
little things that cost
nothing that make other people um feel
like you saw them
that they matter that they're that they
exist um
and that that is that is a that is all
steps we take to
to doing good and of course it can it
can it can grow from there it can scale
from there